it doesn't make any sense but she's
gonna make sense okay take a look the
last year and a half i've been on a
quest to trade a single bobby pin up
until i get to a house after 28 trades
and all the ups and downs i finally did
it
okay
we're walking up to it
this feels so surreal
wow so here to tell this how this insane
true story happened is demi skipper demi
wow
take me back to may 2020 where did this
idea and bobby pin come from
yes so may of 2020 i think like a lot of
us i was sitting in quarantine watching
too much tv and came upon a ted talk
about a guy that had done this 20 years
ago and i looked and he was the only
person so i knew i had to be the second
one to do it so i grabbed a bobby pin
and then started trading
what what's the step what are the steps
you start with a bobby pin and a dream
for a house what do you even do with
step one so there's the bobby pin then
what
so great question so i looked honestly
around my own house and said what do i
have a lot of i found a pack of bobby
pins i have them sitting all around my
house so i took one of those bobby pins
and made my first trade with abby who
was someone i did not know just random
stranger online but now we still keep in
touch so abby wasn't like why are you
trying to hock a bobby pin that i could
find in the bottom of my dirty purse
she instead said like i'm intrigued and
traded a pair of earrings is this
correct
so i knew that she was part of my posse
when she said you know what i will trade
you a pair of earrings i got for my
birthday but you have to invite me to
the house at the end and i was like this
girl gets me she knows me like this is
my person
so you were transparent about the
building blocks of the mission
what an intelligent approach to share
the story because i so believe in a
collective experience and i do believe
we want to lift each other up yeah and
you are living proof that that is the
case ah totally
yes curious though it took you a year
and a half like what did you end up
trading for the house
great question so there are 28 trades
total so i did not just go from a bobby
pin and then got a house and it was over
there were many ups and downs my final
trade was a forty thousand dollar food
truck trailer so it had solar panels a
battery it's everything you needed to
start your own food truck company
essentially and someone traded me that
for the house is it true that there was
a tractor also at one point
oh yes there were three tractors
involved which i drove myself i've never
driven a tractor but that tractor was
part of the trades it then traded for
chipotle celebrity card which is
unlimited chipotle for a year i didn't
know what that was yeah yeah so somebody
traded me for a lifetime supply burritos
and then she traded
for that off the grid trailer that i
just told you about and then that one to
the house and just out of curiosity
where did you park the trailer in the
meantime oh let me tell you i live in
san francisco i don't have a car of my
own this was a journey in and of itself
oh my god san francisco is the hardest
city to park
with a tractor
oh three of them two not one three it's
just me walking down the street with
three tractors so i found a very
gracious friend who had a large garage
okay so i have three rapid fire
questions
are
you full of memories now from this
journey
yes i mean honestly i thought that i
would trade a bobby pin for a house and
i knew i would get there even if it took
five years but you meet so many people
along the way you end up learning so
much about yourself it became so much
more than just is it possible became
like the people and the memories of the
last two years
would you number two recommend for
someone else to travel
this intricate journey that you've taken
absolutely i think other people should
try it i will tell them they will get a
hundred no's on every trade until they
get their one yes so it's not easy but
they can do it
and number three
how is your new house
oh it is lovely i'm so impressed by you
i am so honored that you would share
this story with us because i i it really
is uh one to wrap your head and heart
around i can't thank you enough to me
skipper
who took her life
and changed it and you can too
thank you so much
[Music]